c'est après votre mort vous voulez qu'il
reste une image de vous qu'est-ce que
reste cette image le peintre ou le
cinéaste ou le poète
[Musique]
et de l'underground movies
l'underground movies c'est le cinéma des
profondeurs un cinéma absurde négatif et
signifie en tout de même paraît-il c'est
la grande vogue ici on voit pendant 90
minutes un homme qui dort un long baiser
de 115 minutes ou encore une délicieuse
prêtresse qui répète inlassablement à
l'eau plazaïd
celle-ci c'est Nico l'une des vedettes
de la dolce vita est-ce qu'il a des
références cinématographiques
est-ce qu'il essaie de faire quelque
chose qui ressemble à un travail d'un
autre
un vieux
ça ressemble à rien
on fait tourner la caméra seul objectif
voilà ce que ça donne
200 photographies
identiques mais de taille différente du
président mouts de cet homme
repeint à grand coup de pinceau par
l'américain en divarole
on fait courir le Tout-Paris au musée
Galliera avenue Pierre 1er de Serbie dès
les premiers instants de la croche
a été et demeure aux États-Unis un peu
partout en Europe occidentale une sorte
de vedette inquiétante de l'avant-garde
des arts et des lettres ainsi que du
cinéma mais
si les uns le portent au nu les autres
au contraire
enfin disons que en bref les avis sont
pour le moins partagés
la révolution culturelle au grand
magasin quoi le récupération générale de
la Révolution ça devait arriver c'est le
Warhol le grand récupérateur
du monde l'image de mots est devenue
populaire
comme si on était à l'époque de la
construction des pyramides
quelle qu'elle soit l'oeuvre dans
divarolles a déjà fait l'objet de
nombreuses études consacrées au pape
c'est-à-dire le populaire art populaire
où on voit exalter les objets de la vie
quotidienne
est-ce que vous vous considérez comme un
artiste
[Musique]
après votre mort vous voulez qu'il reste
une image de vous qu'est-ce que reste
cette image le peintre ou le cinéaste ou
le poète
[Musique]